we all mess with each other to make sure
it was you know a conflicted experience
do you want to hear a joke some of these
tricks get pretty mysterious and spooky
so let's get into it number one how
would you respond the creators of
Wednesday had a realistic looking thing
puppet terrorized the streets of New
York
most people screamed but thing was able
to get some laughs he even made a couple
of new friends including plenty of
children and a rat still one nun stuck
out her tongue at him and someone else
kicked him over on his skateboard but in
the end thing returned to his good
friend Wednesday
number two are you easily spooked when
Aubry Plaza found out that the cast of
White Lotus would be spending five
months at a supposedly haunted hotel to
film the second season she couldn't help
but mess with her co-star Adam DeMarco
this wasn't her first time playing a
joke on set but don't worry we've got
more on that later she arranged scented
Reed diffusers and a Blair Witch shape
on his dressing room floor before
proceeding to mess up her own dressing
room and demanding to know who did this
the staff outed her upon reviewing
security footage but Aubry tried
throwing the blame on other co-stars
just to mess with Adam further according
to him I was definitely questioning my
reality for a while there I didn't know
who to trust
number three Aubry Plaza is known for
playing jokes when she and her Parks and
Rec co-star Chris Pratt discovered a
toilet Goblin on Amazon she just
couldn't resist buying one to sneak into
Adam Scott's trailer this little green
monster comes with suction cups so that
it can be placed under your toilet seat
with its arm extended so that when you
open the lid it like jumps out at you
it's terrifying unfortunately she didn't
let us in on Adam Scott's reaction but
we imagine it was surprising
number four these two are always up to
something stranger things Millie Bobby
Brown and Noah schnapp first try to
trick The Duffer Brothers into thinking
Millie was sick by filling her mouth
with water and pretending she was gonna
throw up next they played a joke call on
their costume designer telling her the
venue she had booked for her wedding was
no longer available but it was only a
matter of time before they turned on
each other Millie got together 20
members of the crew and trash bins full
of water balloons to meet Noah in the
parking garage and absolutely invade him
and it's bad number five there was
nothing forced in these reactions the
first time that the child actors from it
saw Bill Skarsgard in full makeup as
Pennywise was while they were filming
the projector scene that made it into
the movie yeah we're all reaction first
time we saw him it was terrifying
producer Seth Graham Smith described the
scene as being authentic to how kids
should be reacting explaining that that
was one of Andy's things in terms of
scaring the kids
number six this was just bad timing Josh
Hutcherson hit a life-sized dummy of a
tribute who had fallen victim to tracker
jackers in Jennifer Lawrence's trailer
bathroom on the set for Hunger Games
Mockingjay adding that it was all
swollen and gnarly looking Josh wasn't
there for the big moment when she saw it
but said I've been told that she
actually peed her pants in reaction to
it apparently he was pretty proud of
himself while Jennifer would go on to
say I hate him I still haven't gotten
him back for that actually if we were
Hutcherson we'd be watching out
number seven Jennifer Lawrence has been
the victim of a few jokes again on the
set for Hunger Games Mockingjay she once
found a Tiffany's box full of crickets
in her trailer it was the most awful
combination of feelings in the whole
world it's like Tiffany's Jeffrey the
crickets were a gift from co-star
Jeffrey Wright who played BT and you
know what the worst part about it was
and they were my trailer for months I
couldn't get them out number eight
Jackson Rathbone hated his blonde hair
for Twilight I just been wearing a hat I
guess double so when co-star Eddie
gathegi gave him a joke call pretending
to be from production claiming that they
wanted him to dye his hair back to its
natural Brown he welcomed the idea
apparently his manager even responded by
saying oh thank God I hated you with
blonde hair imagine their disappointment
when Eddie called back saying it's just
me number nine you can't even trust your
professor Daniel Radcliffe specifically
asked to have his sleeping bag placed
next to his Crush for the Great Hall
sleepover scene in Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban and although he got
what he wanted director Alfonso quarron
teamed up with Michael gambin and Alan
Rickman to place a remote controlled
fart machine in his sleeping bag
we enter completely our own world
although Daniel tried to keep a straight
face it was only a matter of time before
the Great Hall erupted into laughter
number 10. the ET puppet was very real
to the child actors Steven Spielberg
intentionally shot E.T in chronological
order so that he could keep the children
away from the puppet until it was
finally time for their characters to
meet him this means that their terrified
reactions were real although Steven
Spielberg went on to make sure that the
child actors would also form a genuine
connection with the puppet I would go
have lunch with ET a lot number 11. are
you team Batman or team Superman while
on set for Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice Ben Affleck filled Henry
cavill's trailer with a ton of Batman
memorabilia I think it's much better
this way Ben uploaded a video of himself
showing off his work and scribbling over
Henry's face on a dawn of Justice poster
along with the caption Henry I'm
flattered I didn't know you were such a
fan we know hashtag who will win
number 12. not all jokes go as planned
nikolaj Coster Waldo and Peter Dinklage
came up with a great idea for how to cut
the tension during tyrion's courtroom
scene on Game of Thrones for the two of
them to enter the room dancing they
danced from the door to the end of the
hall and even managed to get a crowd of
extras in on the fun and the only
response that they got Upon finishing
from the crew the first aid ego yeah
reset thank you it was it was incredibly
embarrassing number 13 just like Ross
and Rachel we all know this was
inevitable Jason Sudeikis and director
Ross and Marshall Thurber conspired on
the set for We're the Millers to replace
the song playing on the cars radio
instead of TLC's Waterfalls like Aniston
was expecting they surprised her with a
group sing-along of the theme song from
Friends Thurber told HuffPost
entertainment she really loved it she
laughed and clapped although he admitted
her laughter was begrudging laughter
adding that she poked me and Jason in
the ribs afterwards like you got me
number 14. talk about a tune-up the cast
of Moneyball were given golf carts to
move around the set giving Brad Pitt an
idea he rigged Jonah Hill's golf cart to
play Wake Me Up Before You Go-Go
whenever he turned it on but Pitt was
far from done according to Hill he had
it shrink wrapped bright pink like like
neon pink then he attached wedding
things noisemakers under the car Hill
said that Pitt was the Bobby Fischer of
jokes he's 10 moves ahead of you number
15. have you ever heard of neutron cream
on the set for Star Trek Into Darkness
Chris Pine convinced the makeup artists
to distribute Neutron cream among the
cast telling them that they would need
to wear it in dots around their face as
a safety precaution while filming inside
the lab Benedict Cumberbatch apparently
just assumed it's America and there is a
lot of health and safety I didn't just
rub it in I put it in dots around my
face only upon reading his contract did
he realize that Neutron cream isn't real
these sets definitely seem to have a lot
of fun which joke on this list made you
laugh the most we'd love to hear your
opinions so make them heard down in the
comments
thank you